j'ai choisi que ce texte sur lequel je
travaille avec mon équipe et je tiens à
la saluer depuis plusieurs mois soit
inscrit à l'ordre du jour de la première
journée d'initiative parlementaire du
groupe horizon et à parenté que j'ai
l'honneur de présider
il me semblait nécessaire de proposer
une initiative législative susceptible
de lancer ici un véritable débat sur ces
questions et d'inviter chaque parent moi
compris à interroger et à s'interroger
sur les usages numériques de son ou ses
enfants
je suis bien conscient qu'un véhicule
législatif aussi modeste ne permet pas
d'embrasser l'ensemble des
problématiques soulevés par les réseaux
sociaux mais j'espère bien avec votre
concours apportez une pierre non
négligeable à la construction d'un
véritable écosystème global de
protection de l'enfance en ligne en
proposant un texte ciblé sur les réseaux
sociaux et rendu plus opérationnel grâce
aux auditions et consultations que j'ai
pu mener ainsi qu'avec les apports de la
commission je pense que cet objectif
peut être atteint sur un sujet dont nous
ressentons tous l'urgence des enjeux
aujourd'hui le premier smartphone est
possédé en moyenne avant 10 ans dans
notre pays il ne s'agit pas ici de le
déplorer d'avoir un discours
moralisateur ou de condamner les usages
de plus en plus répandus parmi les
jeunes
je pense qu'il s'agirait là d'une
position dont seulement dépassée mais
encore pire inefficace toutefois nous
devons prendre conscience de la
précocité croissante de cette puberté
numérique et de la puissance de ces
outils mis à disposition de nos jeunes
et ne pas nous contenter d'observer les
potentiels dommages
nous devons agir pour poser les
garde-fous indispensables à leur
protection
nos sociétés sont désormais confrontées
à un double défi de santé publique et de
protection de l'enfance le constat posé
par la CNIL en 2021 et sans appel nous
assistons à une massification et une
autonomisation des pratiques numériques
chez les jeunes publics
82% des enfants de 10 à 14 ans se
rendent régulièrement sur Internet sans
leurs parents
s'agissant des réseaux sociaux
spécifiquement la CNIL constate que la
première inscription intervient en
moyenne vers 8 ans et demi et que plus
de la moitié des 10 14 ans ils sont
présents
face à ces constats il existe une
sous-estimation structurelle par les
parents des activités numériques de
leurs enfants l'Observatoire de la
parentalité l'éducation numérique Open
et l'Union nationale des associations
familiales lunaf deux associations que
j'ai pu rencontrer en nom témoigné les
jeunes sont massivement présents sur les
réseaux sociaux et ceux de plus en plus
tôt
mais les réseaux sociaux bien qu'il
puisse être un espace d'opportunité pour
les jeunes utilisateurs sont aussi le
lieu de convergence de risque multiples
qui peut raisonnablement affirmer qu'il
est normal que de jeunes enfants
puissent naviguer librement avec leur
propre compte sur un réseau social
qu'il soit invités par défis à se brûler
un doigt ou à se faire une cicatrice
permanente sur la joue
qu'il soit assailli par des contenus à
la fiabilité douteuse ces fameuses fake
news ou des propos complotistes viraux
alors que leur esprit critique n'est pas
encore pleinement forgé qu'il soit
exposé plusieurs heures par jour à des
standards de beauté inatteignables sauf
recours à la chirurgie esthétique
mes chers collègues vous l'aurez compris
ces risques sont d'abord psychosociaux
avec l'accès à des contenus
problématiques voire parfois dangereux
donc je vais mettre aux voix la
proposition de loi
je vous prie de bien vouloir regagner
vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
donc votant 84 exprimez 84 majorités 43
pour 82 contre de l'Assemblée nationale
a adopter
[Applaudissements]